has social media ever caused an argument
in a relationship yeah oh my God yeah
what if women argued with you or men
about uh the liking game but back when
that was a feature but not like yeah
discussions all the time but I would I
was like I would do it for like
algorithm things so if I know I'm about
to post I'll just like anything on my
timeline because I know they're gonna
look and they're gonna go and like my
thing back yeah that was that that was
the vibe I would like a picture of your
grand your uncle whatever dogs anything
on that timeline at that time I'll just
I'll just think I know be next to me
when I do it's not like I have to do it
in secret but I understand it looks
crazy yeah it looks crazy anything you
pop up because as well it puts it onto
the news feed as well remember when you
can see whatever people
so I used to get into into situations
about that but I think on the flip side
if your girl only follows 90 people
let's say for instance and then and I
you know I mean and then she follows
that one guy you're gonna be you might
you see 91. what is that yeah
so I think it works both ways though
what have you gotten into art my
situation was different where
um a girl slid into my DMs on Facebook I
like went the extra mile on Facebook to
find out that she went college with my
girl
and then how that went was Facebook you
know like when your relationship it says
your relationship with this person I
wasn't that smart when I was below 25
like I said
um so what happened was
um she was like oh when we started
having a conversation she was like oh
but you're in a relationship with this
person hold on a minute I think I went
to the same College oh I did go to the
same college she screenshotted my whole
conversation with the girl and sent it
to my uh my then girlfriend man and that
obviously cool that argument isn't
because you were cheating yeah
um it's essentially like you said it's
one of those like back when you can see
who you liked and what you liked back
when there was a thing is like it was
you with like back back then again we
were young we were dumb we didn't know
where the social media was we grew up we
have social media essentially at the
same time so you would see your partner
liking all these things and then that
would be an argument because
for those who don't know who are too
young to know Instagram means to show
people who you liked like like the
pictures you liked on like his own
separate feed so that feed will get you
girls know this yeah that feed will get
you in trouble did you know that um I'm
not sure if it's the same now but before
on Instagram if you were following under
200 people it wouldn't show what order
you followed people in did you know that
so like let's say your man goes out on
the night out and he starts following
someone new then you know
I don't know if it's still the same
feature in I don't know P updates and
stuff but yeah man those kind of things
get into you get into arguments over
there but wait let me ask you something
right because what you just said bro I
weren't cheating it was a conversation
[Music]
is like a physical situation
you can emotionally cheat all right let
me ask you this because I don't know
Devil's Advocate is it really the end of
the world if he's messaging another girl
thank you oh like I I agree it's not the
end of the world
I just think like if we have open social
media profiles can we really like get
off our high horse sometimes like
because I think that attention is
um to women as sexist to men do you guys
agree better yeah okay so I'm like if we
most of us have open Instagrams and
relationships meaning we can get
attention from high status men and
that's always on the table but if he
sends a message like it's the end of the
world no but if he does what he was
doing
she mentioned me first I was just
responding as rude not to respond what
kind of message we're talking about if
it's like if it's like you know emojis
and stuff like that and I mean if it's
General conversation then you know yeah
maybe that's a bus case it's crazy you
should just look at things like
differently I just no I'm with you
if you're the type of person to like
date for like a long-term relationship
or marriage right
um then it's like like in the grand
scheme of things is a message gonna make
or break your life yeah exactly the
intention about you know I think most of
it becomes that gray area of the unknown
so it's the attention behind the message
all right all right a question because I
don't feel like you're on my side I'm
not okay
she's single
okay
okay so you might agree with me in this
yeah you've been reach out for a while
now I was a situation okay you have a
girl she's not your girl but you know
like you have not it sounds bad like a
backup not a backup you have people on
your phone that you know like you right
now I was in a situation where I was
always with someone from like 16 so when
I wasn't with someone I used to just
grab a girl that I knew like me because
I wanted to feel like it was a fulfilled
thing right so if I'm not with so if I'm
not with you and we've broken up for
like a week and we have a sexual
situation I didn't cheat on you because
we were on a break you know random
fingers bro
[Laughter]
this one though no I hear you what I'll
say yeah is um the moment you are
on a break you've you've fed her to the
Wolves bro you can't and vice versa bro
you're single you're two single people
it's no longer I know it may feel that
you know okay cool we were in a
relationship but
you're not under that Covenant you're
not under that contract that obligation
that verbal commitment anymore in it so
whatever you do it might be frowned upon
it might be whatever but some people
just move on quicker than others that's
all I feel like you're like 20 on my
side now
would you guys work through a message
yeah she would
um
I think no I think the intentions matter
and I think that if he's messaging
somebody else he's already checked out
and I'm I think I'm very strict when it
comes to that like I think that if
you're going to be in a relationship
with me I think that you have to put
some boundaries in place I think you
have to be on the day what if you're on
holiday and then you come back and you
find that he he messaged another girl
because you were away I'm leaving him
I'll be a few minutes yeah no no I'm
leaving him I think I I don't tolerate
anything but because to me it seems a
bit much to break up over a message it
depends what the message is though yeah
it depends what the message is the
intention's quite clear how how old are
you guys again you're what I'm 29 29.
[Laughter]
I'm just thinking because you're you're
29 if you're in a relationship like do
you want kids yes um do you don't have
any kids so you know if you're single by
30 your chance of having a child drops
below 50 so you're actually more likely
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible